i'll tell you this has broken some of
the toughest people in the world the
hardest way cut i ever had yeah hardest
one
um i fought pan am games in 2015 in
edmonton canada on a wednesday
and i won
so i i've made weight on tuesday
i fought on wednesday where i had to
weigh in five percent of my weight class
so 84 kilos
on wednesday i was 84 kilos
i got on a plane
on
that wednesday night and landed
friday morning in sochi
okay so i've traveled now
i got on the scale all my bags got lost
everything so somehow i flew from
there to here
no bags and i threw all of my stuff
in my bag i wore sandals
one pair of pants and a t-shirt on the
plane because i was like
i'm just tired i just fought like i
don't even want to carry it i don't care
what are the odds that i get there my
bags are gone yeah very low very low
sure enough it's gone i get all the way
to sochi i check into the hotel there's
one sauna
guess what you have to reserve it
and you're only allowed to reserve it
for an x period of time guess get a
small tangent
when you found out your bags are gone
this is something i'll often think about
there's like people that are helping you
right like that there's a person airport
who goes
yep oops just like that and then the
person at the hotel who tells you that
you have to reserve the sauna and looks
at you like
you're
yeah they don't care that you've been
suffering they don't know
they don't even understand why you need
it yeah like why oh you know oh this
like uh like this little kid reserved it
for five hours or something to block it
off or so i'm sorry
um is there a frustration that gets in
there are you you just accept reality
don't don't even hinder on like the
things you can't change because the
second you get frustrated the second
you think you can change it you'll harp
on it and that breaks most men yeah
that like little thing in the back of
their mind thinking
oh like what if there's no what if like
there's only right here right now yeah
if it doesn't work it doesn't work let's
just quickly come up with the solution
to fix the problem by the way as another
small tangent all the greatest people
i've interacted with at the highest
level
think like that
they don't linger on the no it's like
the next thing yeah because like if you
want to do something great
heart stuff is going to keep happening
to you and if you're going to let that
affect you you're not ever going to do
the great thing yeah it's fascinating
actually like that's the one skill you
have to learn
um elon musk is great at this constantly
dealing with emergencies okay okay this
happened what's the next step yep
accept it's not that big of a deal every
problem has a solution yeah yeah
and if i can't solve it it's not my
problem
you want me to do it
exactly so what uh so
you figured it out
get this i get to the hotel
i check in
i don't even know about the sauna yet i
go
i need to find a clothing store i'm in
the middle of russia
i open up google maps and i'm like
sports store
i find an adidas sports store in the
middle of sochi russia right
i spend like 500 on like average sweats
no plastics no nothing
and no running shoes because they don't
have any what's the temperature outside
is it cold it was kind of like springish
so it wasn't cold but it wasn't hot yeah
so you still need a lot of layers
preferably
you would need a lot of layers just to
cut the amount of weight i'm about to
tell you i have to cut because
after i bought that stuff that next
morning and mind you it's a friday it's
a friday morning i go to the venue where
we have the mats open to train and i
step on the scale
and then sagan batara mongolia goes
oh pretty good you're almost there
and i go oh no no
no i'm not
i stepped on the scale at almost 94
kilos
and i looked at him and i was like i'm
81
and he went
good luck
you're almost there
yeah
for the next weight class above uh the
this is on a saturday or friday morning
no no sorry friday morning the the
competition is one
sunday sunday i weigh in sunday
okay
all right like holy crap i throw on all
my layers
and there's one other person with me
there khalida who's my girlfriend at the
time now my wife we start doing judo
because i'm like this will be the
easiest way to knock off like three or
four kilos
well it's cold i have no ghee
and i'm working out with a female i
can't get like
overly physical to like really get my
muscles going to really break that sweat
because
she has to compete in a dare to do this
she's not a training partner you can't
just use this person
i stepped on the scale i was 91 kilos
so i went well i was a nice dent but
like workout yeah i go that's that's not
gonna fly
so
sure enough the clothes are now ruined
they didn't help me lose any extra
weight
so i go back to the hotel and i start
reserving the sauna
do you know how hard it is to lose that
much weight in a sauna by yourself
so it's hard on many levels but one of
them is just mental yeah
you're sitting in heat heat and you're
not doing anything like if there had
been a bike or like the sauna was big
enough to use a jump rope or
you could do some sort of activity
but you just sit and you stew
and you're there mentally
at one point during the weight cut i
actually had my mouth on the bottom part
of the door where there was a little gap
and my legs up on the benches and kalita
holding the door
so that it didn't open so i couldn't
open it so that i could lean against
that thing and have fresh air
because i was like i was struggling
and we're talking about i mean how many
hours is that hours and then the thing
is is because you have to reserve the
sauna i can't even take like a 30 minute
break because the sauna's not going to
be mine in an hour
which means you have to use the sauna
and the heat
for that a lot of time period
and i hate saunas yeah that is always my
last resort i would use a bath i will
train i will run i will jump rope sauna
is like
oh let me do that for 10 minutes after
all of my gym workouts just to keep the
sweat going while i stretch and cool
down that's never like the hey i'm gonna
do five ten minute sessions because i
need to lose two kilos that is never the
plan yeah
but i mean uh
so i've done plenty of sauna for weight
cuts to know
i can't even imagine what you went
through yeah the second slow down
that's one way to achieve immortality is
like the time slows down to like a stop
and
you're left alone with your thoughts you
can't do anything just like you said you
can't there's nothing worse than sitting
in that kind of heat for 10 15 minutes
yeah and then you walk out and you're
not even sweating
yeah there's nothing worse than that and
if you like and maybe if you weigh
yourself which you should probably
shouldn't be doing because it'll break
you yep you haven't lost anything yep
and i was weighing myself every time
because
i only get breaks when i was hitting
weight allotments so if i could lose 0.3
in 10 minutes i'd give myself a break
but i had to hit certain numbers
because i only have the sauna for a
certain amount of time and i remember
one time i went downstairs to get my key
to the sauna and the japanese team had
reserved it and took it from me
because the guy didn't put my name on
the list when i called down to get the
sauna so i lost an entire session that i
had to get made up towards the later
part of the day because i still have no
running shoes
and then sure enough
my bags show up 30 minutes after
williams
great
that's like the universe just kind of
giving you a little wink there yeah
i think like
because so few people do this weight cut
at this high of a level people don't
often realize because people get a sense
of how hard it is to run 200 miles in
the desert
like they because they go outside here
in texas you can run five miles oh it's
hard but like the weight cut is really
i can you so you just uh like how did
you do it
just [ __ ] not refusing to you have to
make weight you have to make weight and
you just that's
i am astounded when i hear like
ufc plighters like
miss weight
right like
when jaden cox missed weight at the
olympic trials i was like
at least his was understandable because
he missed the actual
weigh-ins he didn't he wasn't like not
on weight
but when ufc fighters like
miss wait i'm like
how did that happen
you clearly like gave up a long time ago
there were times where i was like
well i can't do this
there have been times where i've been
in a s in a sauna suit
wrestling with a training partner who's
probably 60 kilos who fought earlier
that day
to lose point three
to lose point like are you considering
your mortality in this moment like
aren't you thinking you're gonna die
because like it's severe dehydration you
could damage your body
i do are you thinking about any of this
or no is it just
man
okay yes let's see i'm i'm on the other
level too where like
i've been in belgium right belgium there
used to be a b level tournament and the
tournament used to go on and because i
was always on the heavier side like 81
fights on the second day which is the
heavyweight day
um weigh-ins were always at like let's
say 2pm the day before for that
tournament well there was a sauna at the
tournament i remember like being in the
sauna and like oh
i'm 80.9 kilos
weigh-ins aren't for three hours
[ __ ] it i'm gonna have lunch
because i i mentally understand that
what i eat right now is gonna fuel me
for tomorrow right so i don't want to
skip it
i have the time to put it into my system
and still lose it right
it's almost like a computer program
you're running through the process you
haven't i i get it but like that all
relies on your ability to be um
to get it back off yeah i mean but also
just like go through this process which
is painful it's like those monks who
meditate while sitting in a fire kind of
thing or something right like it that
uh yeah it's a it's really interesting
is there other people
that are critical to this or is this all
internal to you are there people that
everybody has their own
way of doing it um some people don't cut
that much some people can't wait cut at
all right they would rather have been
like
83 kilos fighting 90 than
you know be 83 kilos fighting 81.
so why did you never move up to 90.
what's your sense
is it from your deep understanding of
your own judo and like the judo
opponents you would face at 90
and 81 because 81 is probably the
hardest if not the second hardest
division in the history of judo compared
to 73 and
81. you know when i was a kid like
i always wanted to be like the
middleweight olympic champion like the
81 kilo olympic champion
when i was in high school
i made a decision when i was trying to
make weight for 73 i was like
this is i was cutting weight for 73 like
i was cutting weight at the end of my
career
right and i was like i'm just going to
bag it
i'm going to accept the fact that i may
not make a junior world team i may not
make this team but i'll grow into the
division so when i'm a senior player
like i'm ready to go and i'll naturally
be stronger there's an understanding of
like a growth process when you move up a
weight class
most people can't just
oh i'm going to fight 90s and i'm going
to win because i wanted 81.
the style of judo is different how you
move is different how they do things is
different there's like a learning curve
that goes into it
and because the weight cut didn't really
happen until i was getting ready for rio
i wasn't about to have my last olympic
games be at a different weight class
that i may or may not be able to grow
into
i mean this is an awesome story of you
kind of decided
that this will be your life's work in
terms of judo
competitor is like the 81 division i'm
going to i mean i don't know if you saw
it that way but you're talking about
three olympics and it's like this
story of
i would say tragedy and triumph of just
wars and 81 kilograms with with the
usual cast of characters of the you know
top five in the world kind of thing so
you just became a scholar of that let
your body grow into it and then let your
body outgrow it and still suffer through
it to keep it in the 81 kilograms
you never competed at like at the
highest levels at 90. i entered one
tournament at 90 kilos um and that was
because
before
rio
from 20 from the end of 2014
all the way up until rios every time i
fought i got hurt
every time
there was no time where i made weight
and got injured because my body weight
was so high my body fat was so low
that by the time i dehydrated enough to
get down there
and you take the physicality of judo and
throw that into the mix
something broke everything
it was like nature of the beast
so the plan was
before
rio
we made an agreement with usa judo that
travis you're going to fight 90 kilos
but you're not going to weigh in at 90
kilos like hey there's no like you get
to be 94 kilos and cut to 90s there's
like a you're going to step on the scale
at 84 kilos like a little bit of a
weight cut but not a full one just so
that you feel like you get into like the
tournament
because when i
around 2012 when i was talking with the
usoc nutritionist i actually got my
weight down so much that i didn't really
need to cut weight
the problem is i wasn't cutting weight i
didn't feel like i was competing got it
right there you have to go through like
that mental process and i never really
reworked that it was easier to just cut
the weight and be ready to go
but when i entered into the 90 kilo
division i was rushed to the hospital
the night after because my body broke
out in hives
like full body
they had they said it was stress-induced
fascinating so a month before the games
i was hospitalized and hungry
and filled with steroids to get the
hives to drop and every couple days
my body when i got back home i would end
up in the hospital because my whole body
would break out again i wonder if it's
like deviating from the process that you
so like perfectly crafted already or it
was stressed from my mind thinking like
even though it's not
top of mind there's probably a portion
of me that like the olympics is coming
around and it could be my last
that like my body just reacted to
something chemically so i was breaking
out in hives i actually bought like a
600u
euro
hugo boss suit because when i was in the
netherlands training at the time
i thought i had bed bugs because i was
getting bit everywhere
then i thought there was something in
the detergent at the local thing so i
threw away all my clothes
like i was paying for showers because i
was trying to get the detergent off my
body and buying new clothes at the
airport
trying to figure it out trying to figure
it out just go yeah accepting the
situation i mean but the level of stress
is exceptionally high here
you